voilà une députée qui ne doit pas être
pressé de retrouver ses collègues après
le confinement laetitia via député la
république en marche à paris est en
effet au coeur d'une importante
polémique après avoir été dénoncé par
plusieurs collègues comme ayant tenu des
propos racistes homophobes et sexistes
c'est une enquête de mediapart qui
révèle la sphère dans l'article elle est
accusée d'avoir eu des attitudes
racistes envers un collaborateur
d'origine asiatique qu'elle aurait
surnommé le chinois et qui était devenu
son bouc émissaire autres dérapages
lorsqu'elle s'est adressée à ses
collègues pour évoquer une loi sur les
réfugiés de la communauté lgbt un projet
qu'elle aurait surnommé l'amendement des
[ __ ] plusieurs témoins auraient aussi
rapporté des propos au sujet de la tenue
de ses collègues féminines décoller
qu'elle n'hésiterait pas à traiter de
[ __ ] des révélations qui n'ont pas du
tout plu à la députée qui a décidé de
porter plainte
ironie du sort c'est justement
aujourd'hui que la proposition de loi
présentée par laetitia bien contre la
haine en ligne doit définitivement être
votée par l'assemblée nationale
alors cette histoire a fait énormément
parler aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
quittez ce que vous quittez pas un petit
tour des des chroniqueurs d'abord au
raymond je kiffe pas du tout je kiffe
pas du tout parce qu'elle porte une loi
sur l'anti harcèlement et sur le fait
qu'ils aient le cyber harcèlement contre
on tape sur les gens cachés derrière un
écran elle elle fait pareil en texto à
les députés je kiffe pas du tout ces
comportements là et est une fois de plus
si elles ont la critique sur sa couleur
de peau ce sera la première à dire c'est
pas bien c'est pas bien de faire ça faut
pas faire ça elle a eu des propos
homophobes elle a eu des propos sur sur
le chinois etc etc
mathieu qui j'ai pas du tout qui fait ce
truc là ce truc là jean michel maire oui
bah je devais bras m'en sont tombés
comme des heures le le professeur
d'histoire-géo parce que j'y croyais
même pas c'est pas possible comme
quelqu'un qui porte un projet c'est
comme si un ministre des finances qui
caché l'argent en suisse mais la c b
exactement paille lui elle est une porte
un projet il fait exactement l inverse
sont ces propos à mais en plus elle nie
alors qu'ils les copies des captures
d'écran de cinq témoignages c'est pas
une personne qui dit ça qui a été
licencié ses cinq collaborateurs directs
qui copies de copies d'écran à l'appui
montre ce qu'elle disait elle dit non ce
d'accord je m'excuse j'ai peut-être été
mal compris mais je vais porter plainte
c'est incompréhensible selon valérie
bénaïm tout à fait d'accord avec mes
camarades mais moi ya une chose qui
m'ont qui m'ennuie qui me gêne c'est que
j'aurais préféré qu'avant qu'il donne
des interviews ceux qui ont été harcelés
à mediapart il aille d'abord voir la
justice la police dire voilà via les
captures voilà j'ai été harcelée je
porte plainte et après on s'en fait
l'écho parce qu'effectivement c'est un
personnage public et en
totale inadéquation avec ce qu'elle vend
comme sos donc voilà mais j'aurais
préféré 7 alors on à nicolas bays merci
d'être venu parce qu'il est venue de
lens pour nous merci nicolas parce que
c'est du boulot merci d'être venus
nicolas bes vous êtes ancien député et
la public en marche vous étiez valérie
bénaïm danser que de la télé nicolas
merci d'être là éclairez nous parce que
mine de rien quand on quand on voit ça
c'est ccues qu'on n'y croit pas alors
effectivement on a du mal à y croire
cyril et on je comprends que tout le
monde ici soit choqué par ses propos
après moi je m'inquiète un peu sur la
méthode et je suis d'accord avec valérie
ce pas parce que c'est ma chef
oui c'est ça le calendrier est bien
choisi et raymond a eu raison le
rappelait il ya eu la loi une loi qui a
été votée aujourd'hui que la loi via sur
le cyber harcèlement est typiquement
mediapart est quand même un média à
charge mais sort l'article aujourd'hui
et c'est un article un peu de délation
avec des méthodes de capture d'écran et
autres gens mais la pression des médias
pas franchement moi on va pas on va pas
on va pas non plus l'europe réussit bien
faire ça du bon ils sont forts ils font
du bon boulot mais moi moi je vous dis
rubrecht pirlo bat fort ils sont forts
ils en voulaient faire sont bons c'est
le calendrier qui est assez surprenant
et la méthode
les collaborateurs un collaborateur
le collaborateur d'un député c'est quand
même quelque chose d'une relation très
particulière vous passer plus de temps
avec vos collaborateurs quand vous êtes
parlementaire qu'avec votre famille sûr
que député ces sept jours sur sept et
vos collaborateurs connaissent toute
votre vie à tout venant
peu importe la méthode pardon si elle a
vraiment dit ce que l'on a vu et c'est
vraiment écrit ce qu'elle a écrit ça
c'est impardonnable par sosa c'est
condamnable mais moi j'attends qu'ils
aient effectivement un procès pour voir
comment ça a été écrit est-ce que c'est
pas sorti d'un contexte de l'accord de
tous les échanges mais elle est là elle
avoué à l'avouer à 2008 me dit que voilà
oui mais non il ya faute voilà il ya
effectivement fautes et les poufs ronds
on doit être
les prochains débats c'est vrai que
c'est pas qu'on doit être oui c'est vrai
il doit être irréprochable mais ça rend
pas service au gouvernement de macron
mahilé déjà d'engluer dans une merde pas
possible parce qu'il ya un virus qui lui
tombe dessus ça ne ressemble à personne
ici face à la crise pas possible tout
est pas possible dans ce cadre en
service ailleurs déconseillé car avec
des clopes l'hôtel fait des propos si
vous voulez vous vous tuer il n'y a pas
de sanction en fait on laisse personne
prend la parole pour dire c'est pas bien
ce qu'elle a fait je colle je ne
cautionne pas on laisse on la voit la
salle on va voir on va voir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs là dessus
voilà je kiffe 40%
voilà et 60% et ouais voilà les dénoncer
voilà donc laetitia bien dénoncé par des
collaborateurs pour des propos racistes
sexistes et ovins les gens ne vivent pas
qu'elle était bien né c'est à ce taux de
son côté à 60%
il aurait dû d'abord allé voir la police
jacques rogge